hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the don't laugh
challenge now the rules are simple you
laugh you lose and I've spent the past
few weeks trying to find the very best
of the funny clips that I could possibly
find the problem being I can't watch him
to confirm if they are so I've got a big
assortment here it's not one video it's
a whole collage of various videos and I
and once again going to act as the
filter between you the unsuspecting
audience and the raw unbridled or that
is the comedy contained in these videos
or maybe they're not funny at all but we
won't know until we watch them so let's
get Roy into the funny
[Laughter]
what is this Claire make you think of a
warm summer's day the light of a Sun a
smiling child
maybe it's thing making you think of the
surface of a sunflower thankfully that
guy laughing saved me from laughing so I
didn't laugh laughing OH
trapped in your mind yeah I still don't
think I've lost yet after my own heart
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
jeez I'm not surviving this one
[Laughter]
it's another all right you ain't funny
bring it on sniff bark bark
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I want to [ __ ] die take a closer look
at that mean take a closer look at that
means this is it even I know I have
devolved to the point where anything
will make me take a closer look at that
mean I know I'm sorry I have a gentle so
that's all for this don't laugh
challenge thank you everybody so much
for watching I can't put these videos in
the description because I I assembled a
huge collage of them from various places
on the internet and I don't have a
compilation of them other than this
video but thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to see another
one of these or another type of these
like the don't cringe video let me know
down in the comments below and as always
I will see you in the next video bye